Українська влада широко анонсувала створення Центру протидії дезінформації.
Потенційно офіс Володимира Зеленського та Рада нацбезпеки й оборони бачать його навіть "міжнародним хабом".
Проблема протидії дезінформації вимагає скоординованої діяльності усіх державних установ.
І парламенту, і уряду, і громадського суспільства. І залучення ресурсів не тільки нашої держави, а наших міжнародних партнерів.
Україна вже сім років  - з моменту анексії Криму та від початку війни на Сході України -
протидіє гібридним атакам та є мішенню російської дезінформації.
Ще за президентства Петра Порошенка, у грудні 2014-го навіть було створене ціле міністерство для протидії дезінформації,
більш відоме у народі як "мінстець" - за ім'ям очільника Юрія Стеця.
Тоді сам факт появи міністерства для контрпропаганди викликав чимало критики, в тому числі з Євросоюзу.
І все ж, структура проіснувала до вересня 2019 року, поки її не реорганізували у міністерство культури та інформполітики.
Серед іншого, міністерство відновило трансляцію українських телеканалів і радіостанцій у деяких підконтрольних уряду районах Донбасу,
допомагало акредитації журналістів для висвітлення бойових дій на сході України, збирало докази присутності російських військ на Донбасі.
Новий центр протидії дезінформації - наразі безліч невідомих.
Станом на 16 березня, день анонсованого початку роботи центру, громадськість не дізналась ані концепції Центру,
ані прізвища керівника, ані де розташується його офіс.
Українські офіційні особи додатково заплутують ситуацію.
Адже на базі Мінкультури та інформполітики, вочевидь, буде створюватися ще один центр проти дезінформації. Його мета - схожа:
Нейтралізація впливу дезінформації та маніпулятивної інформації та реагування на ключові теми, в межах яких поширюються фейки і пропаганда.
Чим будуть відрізнятися функції цього центру від хабу в РНБО під патронатом Зеленського і як співпрацюватимуть,
залишилось під знаком питання. Керівник офісу президента Андрій Єрмак припускає,
що в нового центру при РНБО з'являться міжнародні партнери і однією з перших до хабу долучиться Німеччина.
Утім, на момент публікації сюжету жодної офіційної реакції з Берліна на створення центру не було.
Водночас DW звернулася до берлінських незалежних експертів. Вони вітають українське починання.
Важливо підкреслити, що за 7 років війни Україна акумулювала справді величезний безцінний досвід
у протидії усім формам сучасного ведення війни з російського боку, включно з арсеналом інформаційної війни.
І заснування такого центру є дуже корисним. Адже уся інформація, знання, досвід та навички, наявні в українській державі,
розпорошені по різних управліннях, міністерствах та державних органах.
Центр має шанс зібрати усі ці знання докупи.
Український центр міг би стати цінним доповненням до вже існуючих центрів з протидії гібридним викликам Росії
по обидва боки Атлантики, вважає берлінський експерт з безпеки Андраш Рац.
Як заявили DW у Єврокомісії, в ЄС також підтримують українські проєкти протидії дезінформації та вітають співпрацю.
Україна, ЄС та наші міжнародні союзники і партнери стикаються зі схожими викликами.
Тому ми поділяємо наміри обмінюватися досвідом і корисними навичками щодо найбільш ефективних шляхів чинити спротив спільно.
Слід зазначити, що на Заході, відколи почалась війна в Україні, було створено кілька центрів для протидії різним формам гібридних загроз.
У Ризі відкрили центр стратегічних комунікацій НАТО, який масштабно протидіє російській дезінформації.
У Талліні - євроатлантичний центр кібербезпеки. У Гельсінкі працює центр протидії гібридним загрозам.
У багатьох європейських країнах теж були створені власні центри боротьби з різними аспектами гібридних загроз.
Важливу роль у протидії дезінформації з боку Росії відіграє East StratCom Task Force -
Оперативна робоча група зі стратегічних комунікацій "Схід".
Цей підрозділ Європейської служби зовнішньополітичної діяльності створили у 2015 році,
через рік після початку військових дій на сході України.
Все починалося з кількох аналітиків, переважно зі знаннями російської мови.
Спочатку взагалі без власного бюджету, за рахунок країн-членів ЄС.
Брюссельська група мала знаходити фейкові новини та маніпуляції росіян про Україну та спростовувати їх за допомогою фактів.
В основному про війну на Донбасі та щодо незаконної анексії Криму.
Наприклад, лояльні до Кремля ЗМІ нерідко поширюють повідомлення про візити європейських політиків до Криму,
фабрикуючи уявлення про міжнародне визнання анексії.
Насправді жоден вагомий політик з правлячих європейських партій не відвідував Крим.
За шість років у європейській базі даних EUvsDisinfo зареєстрували понад 11 тисяч випадків дезінформації, найбільше - про Україну-
Україна залишається головною мішенню прокремлівської дезінформації. Її стосувалися близько 40 відсотків виявлених фейків.
У 2017-му, перед парламентськими виборами у Німеччині та у Франції, штат страткому розширили до 16 осіб
і затвердили окремий бюджет – 1,1 мільйона євро.
Група мусила дедалі частіше реагувати на дезінформаційні атаки проти Німеччини.
Кремль охоче створює їй імідж "русофобської" країни, використовуючи сумнівні джерела та чутки.
У 2020 році прокремлійські ЗМІ найбільше дезінформації спрямували на тему коронавірусу, поширюючи теорії змов,
дискредитуючи західні вакцини та вихваляючи власну.
Експерти беруть свої дані зі щоденного моніторингу ЗМІ та з висловлювань політиків.
Однак вони рідко можуть простежити шлях фейкових історій до російського уряду,
і група "Схід" майже ніколи не має доказів того, що за якоюсь конкретною фейковою новиною стоїть Кремль.
Нині річний бюджет європейської команди сягає вже 3 мільйонів євро.
Але це все одно незначна сума порівняно з сотнями мільйонів євро, які Росія виділяє пропагандистам Russia Today та Sputnik,
не кажучи вже про неофіційні російські фабрики тролів.
Зокрема через це багато експертів ставлять під сумнів ефективність європейського крихітного "інфовійська",
хоч в цілому і вважають його потрібним.
Європейська команда з протидії дезінформації - дуже професійна, але дуже маленька.
Весь час триває дискусія щодо необхідності покращити її фінансування.
Але поки це не увінчалось успіхом. М’яко кажучи, є багато речей, які можна покращити з європейського боку.
В Єврокомісії прогнозують, що потреба у міжнародній співпраці щодо спротиву інформаційним атакам з Росії
та щодо фактчекінгу буде існувати ще довго.
Тож появу українського центру європейські аналітики називають чудовою новиною.
Під питанням, щоправда, залишається концепція РНБО та ефективність її втілення.